all right javian clowney played last
year with the tennessee titans first
overall pick in the 2013 draft was
2013-2014
they're all blended together it was 2013
number one overall pick of the houston
texans
second visit coming potentially with the
cleveland browns you know last year he
didn't sign until just before the start
of the season the pandemic had a lot to
do with
this year you can actually go on a visit
you can have a
physical you can be properly examined
and evaluated by teams before they make
a decision
and uh hey the browns trying to upgrade
their pass rush
obviously they have a need across from
miles garrett olivier vernon
gone they picked up tack mckinley in
free agency that doesn't solve the
problem
and the idea of a healthy janaevian
clowny that's what's so
yeah alluring about clowney when you see
what he does when he's healthy the f
the play up capacity the problem is he
he doesn't stay healthy long enough to
give you the payoff consistently chris
no i mean he's a really risky signing
you know as far as what you're gonna pay
the player
let alone like you like you're talking
about the injury history it's real
i mean it's always something you know we
know he's got a knee issue but it's been
a
bunch of other issues throughout that
you know
and it's a guy who plays a really
physical
psycho brand of football which makes him
so much fun to watch and when he's
healthy he is an
f to play up dominate the game in so
many different ways and
you know it makes sense from cleveland
you know again we talk about this a lot
right they're they're running that
seattle scheme
joe woods came from the 49ers they want
a front four
and they don't want to blitz they want
to rush four and drop
seven and play their seattle scheme
zones and do
all that and match zones and pass people
off that way
so it's really really important position
for the success of their football team
let alone
they've seen clowney in seattle in that
scheme
and what he can do and and adjust and
fit to that so
makes a lot of sense from their
standpoint but yeah the price it's got
to be in the sweet
spot or make sense for the browns
because clowning is a
a risky investment i wonder what the
play is here is it try to sign him
before the draft
so that they don't have to address that
need or is it have an
idea of what he's looking for so you can
move quickly
to get him if you don't address your
needs
in the draft i'd be i'd be hesitant to
lock into clowney ahead of time because
you never who's going to fall to you
when you're that far down on the board
you don't know who's going to be there
no
what if you sign him and then the guy
that you would have ranked as your top
available pass rusher the way the
dominoes fall hey there he is
yeah oh well we have janae and clowney
no well i mean listen i i hear you what
you're saying there
you know i do think that like the pass
rushers that will be available there
at the end of the first you know i would
think really the cream of the crop ones
are gone
as far as those first round picks mike
so that that to me
i i and i think your question is like
spot on to me that was the same question
i was asking myself too
you know i i think they're doing it to
get wait let's get clowney
we got takaris mckinley like you talked
about we'll get some other guys in there
and now we're good in that department as
far as
looking for another edge pass rusher
yeah now we can
look for one maybe in the second or
third round or somewhere later in the
draft and not have to worry about it in
the first round
because i don't know i don't think
they're guaranteed to pick 26
to have a legit pass rusher
available mike you know you've heard me
talk about jalen phillips the quitty pay
from
from michigan and then the the away kid
from penn state those three are i think
in a class of their own as far as guys
that come off the edge and then it's
like i'm not sure if there's gonna be
another guy that goes in the first round
you know that that comes off the edge
that way so that's probably where
they're thinking
clowny now and then in that ver
end of that first round they can maybe
go linebacker
or you know something in the secondary
to help out their team that way to me
that's where it is
offense they're really good mike i mean
you look at the browns and you go what
do they need
they need nothing they're great perfect
it's all about the defense and just
filling in a few spots there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports